we begin with breaking news from Morocco
where rescue workers have pulled a boy
from a well he'd fallen into and been
trapped there for about four days
five-year-old royan was carried by First
Responders to an ambulance it's unclear
what his health condition is like crowds
have been flocking to the Village of
igran to cheer on The Rescuers several
attempts were made to lift the boy out
of the well but in the end a horizontal
trench had to be excavated to get him
out
[Applause]
those are some live pictures but we will
return to the story once we can get hold
of our correspondent in Morocco
well let's return to our top story which
we've been monitoring coming out of
Morocco where rescue workers have
managed to reach a boy trapped in a well
for the last four days and we believe
he's now been freed Jonas musab al-shami
is at the site of that rescue operation
just bring us up to speed uh on on
what's happening at the moment
hi unfortunately uh the body of Ryan was
retrieved out of the well and he was
declared dead
it was not clear initially people
thought that he was alive but shortly
after he was transferred to the
ambulance wrapped in foil
the the Moroccan Royal Palace delivered
issued a statement where they
um they delivered the news and said that
the king had spoken to his parents it's
a really tragic end the village which
had been celebrating
this
act of uh free angry and did not realize
until now when they went to check their
TVs and read their phones and suddenly
it's gotten very quiet and very grim and
it's just um it's just a tragic ending
to such a dramatic story that a lot of
people had been uh
uh afraid of and had been secretly
hoping that
um
or had almost felt that like that would
happen but had you know clung on to hope
try and reach riyan and to get him out
of this Hillside and everyone had been
anxiously waiting to to get him pulled
out
uh do you have a sense of what have you
spoken to anybody around the vicinity
what have they told you
there was actually not much going on it
was it was a completely joyous
environment like I said people were just
happy that he was his body was finally
being
freed and it were and people were
actually hugging each other some of the
rescue workers had even said that they
thought he was alive
um so it's it's quite it's still a bit
unclear about when this transpired and
when
um uh when
when they found out and I suppose this
explains why the family was led into the
tunnel Fest to go and see their son
which was
um uh which Now sort of explains that
sorry
there speaking to us from the situation
of that rescue operation in Morocco
thank you very much for speaking to us
thank you